Din Djarin, The Mandalorian's titular bounty
hunter, has had a wild ride since he crossed
paths with the Child, also known as Grogu.
Luckily, Djarin has a variety of weapons to
protect himself and his little companion.
Let's take a look at some of Djarin's gear
but be warned, spoilers are ahead.
Mandalorian helmets have long been associated
with the Star Wars creed, and Djarin's helmet
is no exception.
Just like with any other Mandalorian helmet,
Djarin's features a T-shaped visor and entirely
conceals his face.
Also, Djarin's tribe follows the Way of the
Mandalore, a religion where members are not
allowed to remove their helmets in public.
If they do, they can never put them back on
again.
"Why," you ask?
"This is the way."
Djarin has been seen without his helmet in
public only twice so far; in "Chapter 8: Redemption,"
because he was badly injured and needed a
droid to tend his wounds, and in "Chapter
15: The Believer", to bypass an Imperial security
scan.
Mando's helmet also comes with a variety of
features, such as tracking heat signatures,
long-range audio, and detecting recent footsteps
left on the ground.
These perks are especially useful when Djarin
needs to locate nearby individuals, whether
they be enemies or those in need of assistance.
Djarin's Mandalorian armor not only looks
cool, but it is also extremely durable.
It's made out of a powerful metal alloy called
beskar, which is known to withstand blaster
fire and even the might of a lightsaber.
Since Djarin's armor is badly damaged in the
show's sophomore episode, he brings a large
payment of beskar to his tribe's Armorer,
who uses it to craft a new cuirass.
Instead of having a red-and-gray color scheme
in the vein of his previous armor, this shiny
new armor is metallic silver, just like his
helmet.
In "Redemption," the Armorer announces the
formation of Djarin's clan, Clan Mudhorn,
which is made up of himself and the Child.
To coincide with this formation, the Armorer
inscribes the skull of the mudhorn on his
right pauldron as his signet.
Djarin's dual flamethrowers have come in handy
time and time again.
For instance, in "Chapter 3: The Sin," Djarin
uses a flamethrower to torch an attacking
stormtrooper.
He's even been known to bring the heat when
words fail him.
"You understand this?"
"Whoa, easy."
Like any weapon in Star Wars, however, flamethrowers
have their limits.
After Djarin is surrounded by bounty hunters
who all want the Child, he uses a flamethrower
to drive them away, but it runs out of juice
when he needs it most.
While Boba Fett first used a variation of
this weapon in the animated segment from the
infamous Star Wars Holiday Special, the Amban
phase-pulse blaster in The Mandalorian seems
to be much more powerful.
Throughout the course of the series, Djarin
uses this sniper rifle to either incapacitate
or disintegrate anyone who stands in his path.
These enemies can be as big as a Trandoshan
or as small as a Jawa, both of whom were killed
in the same episode.
Djarin also uses the blaster to tase a wide
variety of intergalactic enemies and creatures,
such as stormtroopers and even a krayt dragon.
When Djarin returns to the Mandalorian hideout
with his beskar payment, the Armorer uses
the excess material to build him a special
weapon: whistling birds.
These small guided munitions are placed in
his left vambrace.
When deployed, the projectiles fly through
the air while making a whistling sound before
striking their targets and detonating a small
explosive.
The Armorer tells Djarin that these projectiles
are rare, so he saves them for desperate moments.
Star Wars fans have often associated jetpacks
with Mandalorian culture, yet Djarin didn't
receive his own until the final episode of
season 1.
In "Redemption," the Armorer asks Mando if
he has ever trained in the "Rising Phoenix,"
to which he promptly responds that he did
when was a boy.
The Armorer then gives Mando a jetpack and
sends him on his way to reunite the Child
with its own kind.
The jetpack comes in handy later in the episode
when Djarin uses it to attack a TIE fighter
that's piloted by Moff Gideon.
Djarin also uses the jetpack in the subsequent
episode when he flies out of the belly of
an angry krayt dragon.
However, despite all of its advantages in
warfare, the best part about the jetpack is
watching the Child's ears flop around when
Mando takes him for a ride.
Flash charges aren't exactly commonplace in
the Star Wars universe, but for Djarin, they
are especially useful in "Chapter 5: The Gunslinger."
This episode sees Mando working with aspiring
bounty hunter Toro Calican to capture a wanted
assassin named Fennec Shand.
They soon discover that Shand is using a faraway
ridge as a makeshift sniper nest.
After nightfall, Djarin and Calican use flash
charges to blind Shand so they can apprehend
her.
Before long, Calican decides to betray Mando.
Djarin blinds Calican with a flash charge
and takes him out.
It's not a big loss for the galaxy, though.
In fact, Motto could probably sum up Calican
in two words.
"Womp rat."
Djarin's whipcord has helped him get out of
many deadly situations.
In "Chapter 6: The Prisoner," for example,
Djarin takes on several New Republic security
droids.
Throughout the fight, Mando uses the grappling
hook to behead one droid and uses it again
to bring another one closer to a droid that's
being incinerated.
Djarin later finds himself locked in a jail
cell.
Luckily, he escapes after he uses his whipcord
to tether a security droid near his cell door.
He then rips off one of its arms, which he
uses to open the lock.
Grenades are probably one of the most important
weapons for Djarin.
In fact, we've seen him reach for them in
wildly different circumstances.
One instance where they were especially useful
happens in "Chapter 11: The Heiress" when
Djarin, Bo-Katan Kryze, and two other Mandalorians
infiltrate an Imperial cruiser transporting
valuable weapons.
After flying to the ship, the four warriors
try to take the ship's bridge but end up encountering
a squad of stormtroopers armed with heavy
repeating blasters, all while the captain
is attempting to crash the ship at the behest
of Moff Gideon.
Djarin quickly devises a plan to get himself
and the others to the bridge.
He asks the three Mandalorians to cover him
as he charges toward the remaining stormtroopers.
After getting close enough, Djarin throws
two grenades at the enemies, blowing them
up, and creating a path to victory.
When speaking of self-preservation, a wise
man once said…
"Hokey religions and ancient weapons are no
match for a good blaster at your side."
Even though Djarin knows next to nothing about
the so-called "hokey religion," he almost
always has a blaster at his side.
As he demonstrates many times throughout the
show, Djarin is very proficient with his blaster
pistol.
In fact, the initial fight scene that kicks
off the entire series features Mando using
his pistol to shoot the control panel of a
door, which then slices a Quarren trawler
in half.
And that's just the first of many memorable
scenes of Djarin relying on his pistol to
save the day and the Child.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Mandalorian
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.